okay so rings of Power episode 5 has now
dropped and throughout this video we're
going to be breaking down the plot
Easter eggs and also what we think is
going to be happening in the next one
we're also going to be going over our
general thoughts on the series so make
sure you stick around until the end for
our review now we start off with Nori
teaching language and the ways of the
Hobbits to the stranger really nice
detail here that he has a similar accent
to them which is what he would sound
like due to learning how to talk from
them think it's becoming more and more
clear that at the very least he's a
wizard due to the magical abilities that
he demonstrates later on I think due to
Amazon keeping his identity a secret
that he's likely Gandalf instead of one
of the blue Wizards who emerged during
this time the stranger learning about
the cultures of the harfords could
explain Gandalf's love for the halflings
later in life and view their kindness we
can see why he'd gravitate towards them
he's quite a conflicted character after
realizing that he's also a Peril to this
world and then come the end of the
season that he'll Master his abilities
Nori also brings up cave trolls which
we've seen in live action in the Peter
Jackson in films now I did discuss last
week how I thought he might be elrond's
father erendil who too gets mention once
more in this episode The Source material
had him being a character that traveled
out to valinor and due to completing
this journey he was raised up and
entrusted with carrying a star across
the sky this could explain why the
stranger Came Crashing Down in a
Starfall and also helped to give some
emotional closure to elrond who wants to
see him again think it's more likely a
wizard but that's a super early Theory
time but your son of a [ __ ] ass now
from here we get a banger of a song
performed by Poppy and had me nodding
away and beatboxing over the top of it
[Music]
foreign
anyway they make the perilous journey
across the lands of Middle Earth and we
start at the rovanian hills before
moving to weed Brook and then the under
Cliffs the Great River anduin flow
through this area and it actually led to
Mordor which we know is the Southlands
in the show it's gonna explain how all
the characters end up meeting each other
I'm guessing that's where the harfords
are heading now now they also pass
through the gray marshes and due to the
location of where this is on the map I
think this might end up becoming the
dead marshes that we see in the two
towers it's a really nice scene about
community and family even though they'd
leave you behind to die if you sat down
to tie your shoelace The Stranger
constantly stares at the sky and we then
pick about swear to see some strange
figures that I'm not really that sure on
they are clearly following the footsteps
of the strange air but whether they're
good or bad remains to be seen the
leader looks like he's wanting to do an
Eminem tribute act and he scans the
ground before lurking around menacingly
now potentially they might be Servants
of the dark lord who are awaiting his
arrival which could of course be the
stranger I know Sauron has become this
Show's Mephisto with everyone's
expecting that he's one of the
characters and will the real Sauron
please stand up and these characters
could also be his followers that are
aware of an istari arrival and they
might want to take him out before he
Masters his powers though they appear in
white I think the show is telling us in
the shorthand that they're bad which is
why they stand over the Rocks similar to
how the wolf appeared in episode 1. from
here we cut to a Dar staring up at the
Sun in the sky due to living with Orcs
for so long it's unlikely that he would
have spent much time in its light and he
promises to destroy it which is
metaphorically about him embracing The
Darkness at least we learn he's not
Sauron come the end I think he wants to
blanket the land in darkness which the
fires of Mount Doom would allow him to
do we'll also talk later on about what
we think the blade is a key to but he's
clearly trying to mimic the Deeds of
morgoth as we saw in episode 1 he
destroyed the two trees out in valinor
which at the time were what gave light
to the world these were poisoned by the
giant spider and golient and they were
destroyed which is when the elves rose
up Adar likely wants to create Darkness
throughout Middle Earth and this would
of course allow for his Orcs to roam
free without being restricted to the
Shadows I love the character's design
and as many of you pointed out his armor
is full of river shapes calling back to
his conversation last week about
Valerian I think he spent a lot of time
along rivers like this but then he was
captured by Sauron and possibly tortured
we see how he later reacts to the dark
lord being brought up and potentially he
was corrupted and deep down hates what
he's become still he serves as Sauron
who was known for torturing those he
captured in an attempt to make them
become one of his subscribers who also
like the videos might I just had now
Bronwyn announces the deal at Adar has
offered them and some of the men end up
going to him in an attempt to join his
forces this includes waldrake who we
know had the blade buried beneath his
born the men of course once swore
Legions to morgoth and he sees it as a
way to survive the oncoming Slaughter
weirdly he doesn't take Theo with him
and my guess is that the blade is now
bound to him which is why he can't just
take it as a gift might just be some bad
writing but either way from here we go
to numenor I was kind of hoping we'd
skip the 10 days that they talked about
last week but we get it all filled in
and honestly I don't think it progresses
the plot that much you watch them
loading up the ships and can see a horse
being lowered in which explains how
they'll have them when they arrive on
Middle Earth the majority of these
scenes are centered around belindio and
his crew training whilst the sealed or
desperately tries to get on board his
father wants him to earn his place and
he's very much aware that his position
could be a way to give his son a
shortcut to the top he doesn't want to
do this though and rejects his request
to skip the line like Phil and Holly
this very much sets up how a seal door
just wants power without really working
for it and it explains why he doesn't
throw away the ring this will give him
the power he craves without really
having to earn it and the pieces are all
slowly stung to slot into place belindio
is also a character whose name might
have roots in The Lord of the Rings
mythology belindio was the youngest of a
sealdo's four sons and he clearly named
him after the friend who put him through
his Paces the Aryan cries out of
farazone so that he can put a stop to
things and eventually Kamen goes out to
destroy one of the boats though last
week I said I thought he might be
working for his father to gain her trust
I actually think that he genuinely cares
for her in the books as far as our man
zaku to take over the kingdom and we are
slowly seeing the pieces of this fall
into place he might even have Hal brand
as an Insider which is how we see him
working as a blacksmith we learn that he
earned his Crest last week after he
handed Galadriel over and he's clearly
just after his own best interests he's
called before the Council of Galadriel
Muriel and farazone and plots out the
enemy's plan this includes pointing out
the terror of ostrich which is where
Aaron dear and Co are currently held up
alran is told that he'll be leading a
fellowship and hey they said it I was
very much a reluctant King similar to
Aragorn and though it's thought that he
could be Sauron I just don't see it I've
had a lot of conversations with nerd of
the Rings about this and he thinks that
the conversation about controlling your
enemies and whispering in barazone's ear
pointed it towards a b him barazone in
the box is manipulated by the dark lord
in attempting to steal a kingdom and
he's tempted with the secrets of eternal
life however I think that Hal bran is
more likely going to become a king
that's corrupted into becoming an ad
school and on the opposite side of this
elindia will rise up also knit of the
Rings did a great live stream with
director Wayne Yip who confirmed that
the sword we saw last week was indeed
narsal I theorized it was and they held
in it for so long I was like that's a
bloody perfect thumbnail image was
literally filmed like it was for
YouTubers and the director also said
that the background image was Baron and
luthien this was the moment that Baron
pried the cell morale from All God's
crown and it is a big moment in the
source material now Galadriel wants to
use Hal brand to unite the people in the
South but he sees he's being used like
he used hair back with the Caravan World
tracks once more signal danger and this
is of course a call back to the start of
episode 1. this time there's far more
though and we see that the landscape is
being slowly corrupted with a forest
being bare the dark lord is poisoning
the trees which we also see reflected in
London later on this is something that
also appeared in an Unexpected Journey
when we saw how radagast the Brown's
home was being corrupted due to the dark
lord rising up the Wolves end up
attacking but the stranger best them
using magic we see how he can control
many elements including the Earth but
the use of this magic always exacts it
toll whether it's the fireflies dying
Largo's foot his arm looking like it's
from Requiem for a Dream or the water
turning to ice it all comes with a cost
this is something that we've seen in The
Witcher with all magic taking some form
of life I feel like he will end up
gaining a staff which will probably
allow him to properly yield it elsewhere
we watch Galadriel putting the soldiers
through their Paces but sadly I kind of
felt this training scene was a bit
pointless they just showed up in Middle
Earth being able to do all this stuff
then I don't think that anyone would
have minded we have just three episodes
left so spending time on things like
this when when not really getting
anywhere felt like a bit of a waste of
time to to me now it is well
choreographed with it almost being like
a dance but I'd love to see fights like
this against the Orcs rather than them
just being used in numenor bloody
numeral Never Gonna Leave it now
Valentino manages to get a cut in so
he's promoted to a tenant and Hal ran in
a seal door a boat swept up in the
action Kevin wants fire zone to try and
stop the potential war with his people
but the former of course knows that
Muriel will be at the Kingdom and with
the King too weak to stop him he'll be
able to seize control be cut immediately
to the king and he warns his daughter
not to go to Middle Earth foreshadowing
the darkness that's about to befall the
kingdom now after this train you put
sonori on Ice we jump to a dinner party
between the elves and dwarves have a
mentioned it so far but the Dwarven
guards that wear face masks are similar
to the ones from the first age who had
this over them to stand immense heat it
was even capable of blocking dragon fire
and is likely for some of the furnaces
and also General attacks girl glad
common Sunset furnaces and also mentions
the burning eyes of Orwell possibly
foreshadowing the burning eyes of Sauron
during trick salmon are showing some
respect by pretending the dinner table
is a sacred stone and this kills off the
questions quicker than ones about prince
Andrew when some Royal correspondent
says it's not the time of place later on
jiren asks for the news to be given to
him raw which reminded me of Gollum
talking about fish in the two towers
that night gilgalad gets elrond to
recount the story of the Lost silmarells
which we learn were hidden within a tree
Bain or created somewhere else and they
contain some of the light of the two
trees that we saw in episode 1. it's
believed in the Legends at an Elven
Warrior attempted to protect them
against the balrog and when lightning
struck the tree a power was created
within the rock he says mithril contains
a light of the silmarells and tells
elrond about the corruption laying waste
to the land at this point I believe we
see a water basin similar to the mirror
of Galadriel which allows those who look
into it to see potential future events
the fallback story of it is unknown and
similar to narcel it might be an Easter
egg just laying around in the background
he talks about how the light is fading
and that the elves are dying out the
corruption by morgoth there ravage the
Earth which is why they fought to remain
behind to protect Middle Earth in the
end they left a valinor which was no
longer a physical part of Oda aka the
Earth it was beyond the Spheres of it
and it's where the elves returned to in
the end the elves want to gain vast
quantities of mithril as a light of the
cell morals will saturate them in a way
that stops them from decaying but it'll
likely cause a lot of conflict with the
dwarves I think the two sides greedily
digging so deep will be water notes of
balrog and we potentially even heard the
roar one last week during the cave
collapse scene
we get a speech about elrond's Dad and
this reminded me a lot of the one from
fellowship where Gandalf talks about how
all people who face adversity wish it
wasn't them next we go to numenor and
see what I believe is a statue of our
end deal here we see his hands stretched
out almost in a welcoming way which
shows how the men used to Welcome All
who'd come into the kingdom the statues
are similar to The argonath however the
hands for those who put up in a way that
almost said stop it shows that the
mindset of the man changed over time and
that they went from initially being
welcoming to wanting to keep themselves
to themselves we can see a star shining
bright in the sky which may be the one
that Arendelle carries the gem on his
Warhead lights up similar to it so a
scrap the entire part of my video about
the stranger being him now moving on the
numenoreans are partying like it's 19
1999 BC I don't know and uh isildo comes
back groveling and what I think might
even be the same alley used for the
fight against Hal brand after he gets
his back alley beatings it's still not
forgiving and thus he tries to be a stow
away on the ship there's some mention of
him finding something one day that he'll
be prepared to sacrifice everything for
but yet no prizes for guessing what that
is Kevin climbs aboard the bow to do
some awesome which is where the page you
get out this causes the ship to set on
fire and he pulls his potential future
brother-in-law in the pair end up
covering for each other and I wonder if
this debt will come back around in the
future with them both operating in the
political structures that night
Galadriel apologizes to Hal brand for
using him and though her character is
getting online for being a Karen I do
think that's the whole point she's
completely unlikable always asking to
see the manager and keeps telling people
that they have to help her fight Sauron
I think the series is very much about
her learning that's a bad way to go on
and that she gets much further by
actually trying to work with people
instead of against them halbrandhin said
he had to do some bad things to get by
and he might have even worked with Adar
at some point in the past his speech
about how he did what he had to to
survive is interwoven with the man
pledging their allegiance and therefore
I think it's kind of tying in with that
now he might have even had to kill
people and if he's not Theo's father
then potentially he's the one who made
him disappear this would cause issues
with him and Bronwyn and he clearly ran
away for a reason great speech by
Galadriel about how Vengeance has
consumed her but it comes a bit late at
the 50-minute Mark as she gives halbrand
back his true family crests to the Kings
which he ends up taking in the morning
while Drake has to cut the character I
[ __ ] hate and they give me the knife
I'll [ __ ] do it
anyway back at the tower Theo shows
arondia the blade and arundia shows one
of the wall murals built by the man that
swore loyalty to the Dark Lord this
clearly shows the blade in it and
arundia describes it as a key in episode
1 we heard lots of talk about how the
Orcs were experimenting with how to
access the Unseen World which I think is
where Sauron is likely hidden out the
blade will be able to pull him out from
that and that's likely why the Orcs are
after it with the incoming Slaughter I
think it's gonna end up being used as a
weapon to stop them and if it's also
Mogul blade then it could cause some
real Devastation I also think they're
going to bring the tower crashing down
on the Orcs next week as they have a
light bulb moment when they talk about
how it will fall but let me know below
exactly what you think the beacon on it
is lit up almost like a waypoint and the
Orcs all storm towards it jiren enjoys
having the fate of all the elves in his
hand but in the end he agrees to hand
over the mithril they're gonna have to
dig deeper to get more and as we know
Kaza Doom ends are falling so everything
is kinda signing up for us to see that
play out he returns home with his table
for diesel and we end with them finally
finally finally heading out to Middle
Earth Al Brown wears the classic Brown
armor of his people and I got lots of
flashes of the Riders of Rohan in the
helmet design which comes out the top
like it's almost a ponytail ponytail
because it's related to horses but
either way it's a really great way to
end the episode and I was talking about
this with Greg from real Rejects and he
was saying that it's basically the
streaming show effect where they end on
their best stuff to try and make you
forget how slow Pacey other things were
sadly I agree with him and I think they
could have started the episode like this
without us really losing a beat in the
angle Adriel shows up rocking hair oh
man and we know from the trailers that
she's gonna be wearing this a lot and
that kind of segues into my next part of
the video which is the review
unfortunately this felt a bit like a
filler episode to me for at least the
first 50 minutes though it picked up at
the end there wasn't really that much
that got me on board I think a lot of
this stuff could have been condensed in
a time when I was hoping that the series
would pick up we're not much further
forward than we were last week I was
really thinking that after they
announced the voyage at the end of the
last time that we'd hit the ships but we
focus on things like the training of the
crew and I think everyone would have
been completely fine if they just
arrived in Middle Earth and had the
skills that they learned here I know a
lot of people are fine with the show
taking its time but for episodes that
cost 60 to 70 million dollars I am
wondering if they could have spent the
budget on things beyond the costumes in
set I think we really need some big
action scenes to break up the dialogue
and while so now people will be rolling
their eyes and thinking that I'm an
idiot with a short attention span it
would add some Dynamics to the series I
think there's not really been all that
much character development in the five
hours either and after lots of highs and
lows in the first two episodes Galadriel
to me has been almost the same in every
single scene since we've had a couple of
bursts here and there where she realizes
she's just set on Vengeance but most of
the time she's just repeating what's
already been established the sealer is
the same as well and as one of the the
most interesting characters during this
time sadly they just have him constantly
arguing about his duty with his dad
rather than actually putting him in
situations where he's gonna need to make
very tough decisions I think the
audience really needs to care about
what's going to happen with him and I
want it to feel like our hearts are
ripped out when we see how he's
corrupted by the ring I kind of feel the
series also needs a MacGuffin beyond the
blade and for a show called rings of
power we still haven't had them Lord of
the Rings of course had the ring and the
quest Center on that The Hobbit trilogy
was about going to the mountain and
taking it back but I'm still not sure
what this series is really focused on
though they're obviously gonna be going
to Sauron the Bloods don't really feel
all that connected yet and we're just
kind of watching everyone travel to the
Southlands to obviously meet up but they
don't know why now I am very torn on
whether to keep covering this and I
might just miss episode 6 and 7 and then
come out with a big ending explained
video for the finale I think it was
wrong dropping this at the same time as
House of the dragon as you instantly pit
them against each other and that feels
far more of an interesting show to me
and there are good bits in this and I do
try and film my reviews with positives
too though I initially thought the
Harford stuff was a little slow they're
ironically the ones making Headway in
this episode love the mystery
surrounding the stranger and the little
breadcrumbs that they're leaving for us
as to what's going on with him there's
those weird creepy followers too and I
think this stuff with elron and jiren
also helps to elevate the show lastly is
Adar who I think is a great villain and
considering he's a new creation it's a
wonder that the other newbies aren't
this well written the irony at Bronwyn
and Theo stuff also had some good scenes
but overall it's just it feels very
imbalanced I am happy that they're
finally getting out of numenor and I'm
hopeful next week we'll raise things up
once the pieces stop falling into place
hopefully we'll get to see the scope and
scale of this series used for more than
just talking and I'm hoping that the
next three episodes knock it out the
park so overall summary slow start that
got good towards the end but it needs to
have more of these moments earlier next
week week especially if the run times
are getting longer it puts the mid in
Middle Earth for me and though I don't
think it's as bad as everyone else is
saying I feel like there's a lot of
missed potential here obviously though
I'd love to hear your thoughts if you
agree if you disagree it's all fine
don't mind whatever you say you guys
have your own opinions and that's
totally cool so yeah leave them Below in
the comments and as a thank you you'll
get entered into a competition where
we're giving away three copies of dollar
and thunder on the 15th of October all
you have to do to be on the chance of
winning is like the video make sure you
subscribe with notifications on and drop
a comment below with your thoughts on
the episode we picked the comments at
random at the end of the month and the
winners of the last one are on screen
right now save that to you then message
me on Twitter at heavy spoilers you want
some else to watch then make sure you
check out our breakdown of House of the
Dragon which will be linked on screen
right now we've gone over everything in
the latest episode had a blast with it
so definitely head over there right
after this by the way thanks for
sticking through the video I've been
Paul I'll see you next time take care
peace
foreign